head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
I think I think this is also an argument
for why DeSantis could be a better
candidate than Trump because I think
that sometimes people go to vote against
Trump yeah we were that conversation
about Trump and uh going head-to-head
with the sanus earlier maybe nervous
because and you actually brought up his
the way he let the pharmaceutical
industry take over the covet narrative
rushed us experimental vaccine through
gave fauci the podium and like carte
blanche is really concerning to me I he
did the opposite of what DeSantis stood
behind and DeSantis stood behind a
record of not going into any of this
bull crap and I think that's going to be
the biggest difference desantes is like
Trump without NPD
could be yeah it's NPD I know you
narcissistic person I think Trump's
hilarious like I will watch Trump for
hours laughing until I Cry he's so funny
one of the funniest guys I've ever seen
but I think he may have NPD to be honest
so so Rebecca Jones was running against
Matt Gates did she really expect to beat
Matt Gates
she lost
she's got a criminal trial coming to put
over but they called that it's just like
did they really you think you're gonna
beat Matt Gates that's ridiculous come
on and and you know I'll concede Trump
absolutely hilarious a genius word Smith
he's awesome and when he's on stage he's
a master orienter like like the way he
could move curator
potato but but he's really good at
aligning the podium and like yeah yeah
oriented he's also going to go down I
think we'll appreciate him more when he
passes he's gonna go down as a living
legend imagine looking at him in 300
years from now these old speeches that
he did he's gonna go down as an alleged
sounds like they may be calling it for
kemp let me see if we have any uh for
duski's saying that zeldom will be the
first Republican to carry Staten Island
in a governor's race since 2002 and it's
not even close Brian Kemp wins political
poll decision desk hdu predicts Brian
Kemp has won Georgia Governor Stacy
Abrams lost wow I'm so surprised
so so here's the issue they are calling
it how could there be a red Mirage
they've called it there's no way they
uncall it that would be insane
well
three o'clock in the morning and a whole
truckload of votes come in I don't know
that's why I I said poll Watchers should
be sitting outside these buildings with
a with a 360 view of them all night
chilling in lawn chairs enjoying a bag
of pork rinds you know what's funny I
have my poll Watcher certificate sitting
on my coffee table right now and I'm
here so did you do it before poll watch
before I'm technically an elected
committee person in Philadelphia and so
they just gave me one but I had prior
obligations oh no Stacy Abrams she lost
get out of here what were they thinking
DeSantis came out today in his victory
speech and said Florida is where woke
goes to die
I think he's been hitting the right
chords again I'll be critical of him uh
I'm still I'm still unaware and unsure
of his foreign policy but just to
continue the conversation I know you
were waiting to butt in Ian's comments
about big Pharma
they're calling they're calling uh
Colorado for Michael Bennett overall day
a lot of people thought that was going
to happen so we'll see it's only 43
reporting but they're calling it so they
called it there's a lot towards the end
that I was unhappy with Trump for one
was like when he was advocating for the
two thousand dollar stimulus and the
other was his push of the vaccine
lockdown yeah he supported lockdowns
he's two weeks two weeks to slow the
spread honestly I I was very unhappy
with that however the whole the whole
thing seemed to like start falling apart
I remember that he had an aid that
worked for him whose father died and and
he said to Trump at one point he's like
not only did I lose my father I lost my
job and you lost the presidency like it
was like it was
um something they didn't under they
weren't prepared to hand like deal with
the New York Times needle has for the
Senate has ticked one degree to the
right oh yeah it's still a toss-up but
now it's off center slightly to the
right this is what's going to slowly
throughout the night it's gonna slowly
start going down and down and down it's
going to lean right very likely
Republicans so I hope you're right from
your lips to God's ears well but at the
same time the chance of winning the
house has actually gone down three
points since the beginning but we'll see
I really it wouldn't it wouldn't be
weird if they lose the house but win the
Senate that's like 5 30 5 38 said there
was no chance that could happen yeah I
mean it's going to be interesting to see
what happens we might be up for a while
until we actually find out what we
should bring up some of those Farm hot
dogs because yeah I want to I want to
talk about that but wait I want to I
want to kind of continue the
conversation with DeSantis here a little
bit because this is an interesting
conversation that I think a lot of
people are interested in Mike cernovich
just tweeted Miami-Dade Democratic
stronghold DeSantis 2018 versus 2020
look up those stats then tell me he
can't win POTUS in 2025 I'm not saying
that's what Mike cernovich said right
now you can't win I'm saying that he
shouldn't be the choice but we shouldn't
rally behind him just yet I'm not saying
that I don't like Santos I'm saying that
we should rally behind Trump first he's
the one that's going to go in there I
mean think about it if we're talking
about him having narcissistic
personality disorder he's gonna go want
to destroy every single enemy that he
he's ever had he's going to literally go
scorched Earth he DeSantis won't be that
motivated to do that knowing that he has
two terms to run so let's have Trump
first and then go CBS CBS News hasn't
called Pennsylvania Governor but they
are saying it is currently heading
towards Shapiro
see what I want I want Republicans to do
is take it easy for the next two years
don't start like they're great they're
doing any super radical you know they're
great at that policies or anything like
that and then make sure that we maintain
the house the Senate and the presidency
in 2024. insane look at this look at
this Vanity Fair cover from Beto
O'Rourke he says quote I just he says I
want to be in it man I'm just born to be
in it apparently not nope sorry dude
bye-bye he's crying yeah he's got to do
like a really hot dance to get people on
his side are you going to play this
video you did do it and it cost him it
wasn't hot that's a problem but I mean
he really needs to like open up some
sort of rock star inside him if he wants
to Beto has has now lost a senate
presidential and governorship race oh
man I mean he is he is a well that's
that's three for three that's a hat
trick he's officially a loser well you
got to be careful Lincoln was a loser
too Lincoln won because of a split vote
that's interesting yeah big split four
four parties I think he had like it was
four 31 of the vote he won or something
like that so uh currently over at
Reuters it's really close Warnock is
only up by about 26 000 votes 26 500.
it's about 1.1 percent with 72 reporting
so
we'll see man we've got a couple areas
that look like they may go red we'll
we'll see we don't know for sure it
looks like some of the Atlanta and some
other major cities have have had their
results come in to a great degree but we
will see do you think that the Trump
DeSantis situation is actually setting
up a situation where Trump demonizes
DeSantis so much that the mainstream
media Gets behind to Santos which I
think you mentioned they already are in
a lot of ways but like big money
establishments like Black Rock comes in
to be like anything that's going to make
sure Trump fails we want and then they
push DeSantis to the top and it's like a
5D chess move from Donald Trump to get
the Rhonda I would kind of question that
a little bit because I I do see a lot of
mainstream media hit pieces on DeSantis
I see them attacking him not just during
covet during covet they said that he was
going to be the Butcher of Florida that
that there was going to be a bloodbath
in Florida because he didn't Implement
any restrictions or any kind of larger
mask mandates that obviously didn't
happen but the attacks still continue
and and I believe they're they're
persistent from what I see because I
don't see any kind of Mainline corporate
pieces propping him up I see he's
fighting the corporate media a lot but
obviously when I say The Establishment
I'm talking about the right-wing
establishment I'm talking about the
McCarthy's and and like the general
um the packs and things like that
they're they're more on his side than
they are on Trump's side because they're
sitting there saying okay he's the he's
the tolerable Trump he's the one that's
going to not you know say stupid things
at rallies and the problem is though is
that that kind of behavior also can
instigate riots right I mean when you
like you don't look look
I'm on your team on this but do not
think that the way that he handled the
George Floyd situation kind of provoked
a lot of what happened no you don't
think he provoked it at all no I don't
you don't think there was any other way
that he could have spoken about it that
could have de-escalated the situation no
no
they they set anti-fund black lives
matter went around setting fire to DC
before the dude was even in the in
office anything yeah but there's there's
there's so many ways that I think that
he could have de-escalated the situation
and I felt like he intended Trump or
DeSantis right now dude
and I understood his perspective
completely but but you know but I can
put myself in the head of somebody else
but see I think the issue you're lacking
is and most people watching probably
understand I think you very much
overestimate the good faith of these
people they when when they went around
smashing and destroying and killing
people the media lied for them and they
lied for it when Jack passobic got
punched on the street and the cops saw
it happen and walked up this anti-woman
goes nothing happened I didn't see
anything they just outright are lying
these are these are not people you can't
come out and be like we're gonna try in
a piece I mean look at Twitter right now
Elon Musk went to these welt groups we
got pissed about it and he said I'm
gonna work with you they did not care
they came out in the press the next day
and said he is a bad person making
everything worse and then he tweeted I
went to them and told them we're doing
what you want and they're still
attacking me there's nothing you can say
to an angry mob that just wants okay so
so in in the protests what percentage
would you say would be far leftist and
what percentage would you say would be
mainstream people in like the so which
part of specifically like BLM um yeah
like during those riots what percentage
of people were kind of mainstream that
that genuinely believe they're 90 wait a
minute mainstream no no 90 of the people
smashing windows and burning things down
were mainstream normal people who were
not politically uh involved so was there
so with the people that are extreme I
agree with you completely but was there
any way to de-escalate it with the
average mainstream person yeah
I had so many regular friends that were
like we got to get out there we got to
help and uh what like by Smashing
potatoes but you're thinking they
believe that you're thinking about it
political people there were people that
were didn't care about politics at all
and just wanted to steal stuff right
like they were just opportunities but
what percentage of those people that
were out there would you say are like
that or far leftist and what's up
no no the far leftists make up between
like eight and twelve percent of
politics right now of the country yeah
most people who go out were frustrated
with the lockdowns and weren't outside
for months a lot of people who
conservatives tend to live in in
suburban and rural areas so for us like
I remember Ian's making fires in the
fire pit in the backyard during
lockdowns we go back out in the patio
where we can skate where we have our
backyard to half acre not very big but
we're chilling outside we have some
burgers we grill or whatever for people
in New York City you couldn't leave your
your studio apartment you're literally
some people have no windows their
Windows look at brick walls they're
locked in okay but when the riot started
they just said I'm outside I don't care
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time